let me let me see this video nick
the bank club oh sorry about costumes or
homemade
say goodbye
bye gangnam buzz she said store-bought
costumes are homemade
that's a good question that's me also um
i would say oh homemade's the best well
made by far
listen if you buy it at the store one
time me and my brother went to halloween
party in denver is freezing out
my brother decided by a costume of a
penguin we showed up the party there was
17 other [ __ ] penguins
my brother got all drunk fought the
other penguin
yeah [ __ ] these other penguins up man
yeah they do that it was a real penguin
war exactly what i'm talking about
yeah every winter they fight each other
to see who can keep the eggs
yeah jason and the man will go away for
months j shop fought these other
penguins
they steal eggs too right yeah yeah
penguins [ __ ] man
yeah they're just doing the best they
yeah they do go hard that's a good point
job got drunk
went hard in the paintings in his
costume did he steal somebody's egg
he really went out and pushed another
penguin over a couch
oh damn okay but it's also very easy for
a penguin to fall over a couch i feel
like
yeah you know you have no yeah they
waddle when they walk
yeah they ain't got no knees point is
homemade's way better because
then it's more original but homemade
also is risk hey man i remember having
to make my own homemade growing up and
so i was like
i remember doing um a
archer one time like a peter pan archer
and you mean robin hood yeah robin hood
yeah
so i did so much like monofilament line
trying to keep it all together though it
looked like like a busty a you know in
the front and back
some tips oh i had tits in the front end
tits in the low tits in the bag
dude yeah it's disgusting
i was a child but uh yeah so sometimes
man it's it's unbelievable you know it
was like a 200 pound test line dude so i
couldn't get out of that [ __ ] bro
my whole body started to my arm started
turning blue from like blocking off the
blood well that shit's dope nobody else
had it like my french robot you ain't
never seen
that on the streets you mean you haven't
what's up
that's the only picture i've seen
homemade all day man
yeah and what else did what were you
when you were a kid jen
you don't remember you said i don't
remember what
you were alive when you were a kitchen i
know i know my halloween costumes when i
was an adult
okay yeah you want to hear those yeah
sure i dressed up
as bobby lee no you know there's like
clubs
you can go to for halloween you're
adults it's called a party the party
so i would get those fake gold chains
and silver chains
with pendants mm-hmm i'll make fake type
cultural appropriation
fake tattoos and i bought a big woman's
fur coat and then i would do magic
tricks because i was reading that book
the game
i was picking up girls doing magic
tricks this guy
dice and it worked did it yes
i'll tell you this story
thanks for taking us through that shitty
john grisham novel yeah
jesus were you david blaine we're gonna
buy that story at the airport
it's horrible here's what i'll tell you
dude is
one time i did jesus christ bro jesus
christ
okay and my girlfriend was the devil and
i made a real cross out of wood and
brought it to a party then we carry that
the whole night you did yeah it was like
a 45-pound cross too what a terrible
hormone what a terrible idea though it
was exhausted
oh but i i did not give up dude i made
her carry it once i went to the bathroom
oh i bet that looked weird
yeah yeah
but was he a spicy uh satan though yeah
yeah
he was some big horns out the front yeah
tits yeah
a tail off the bat some milk horns yeah
yeah
and then what else dude one time oh i
was pedophile a lot when i was in
college make sense
pedophile was great because here's what
you could do you could
uh you could hit on young girls
no you could oh you just had to be real
quiet get a mustache
like a shirt that has like some leather
on the
oh like those pouches put some
markers in your pocket the glasses get
the glasses mustache stand over off it
in the distance
get you a little beer maybe a little
coat oh you would need wine coolers
oh yeah but i don't know if i had any of
that mike's hard work
oh that too oh dude mike was hard
pretty lame joke really i wouldn't have
laughed at that
but your delivery was great though thank
you i appreciate it yeah
thank you mop jesus christ
the only supporter here is coming from
my brother
[Laughter]
i'll get you that dirty mom i'll get you
it's only a day
what else did i dress up as man i was
pedophile a couple years i was
where's waldo one year before everybody
else was where's waldo i was where's
waldo before anybody had done it where's
super popular i was before that my
friend todd drank some gasoline
and uh and he had to go to the hospital
i bet he got lit uh he's never been the
same he wasn't the same before it though
yeah he wasn't much before it but um
what else did i do me and my brother in
college dressed up as two nerds but now
i look back on it we look like two
pedophiles because that outfit you just
described is exactly how we dress
that nerd nation oh one time i was on
this cruise ship and they had uh
we were limited costumes and people were
you know this one fellow sold his pubic
hair to be used as a mustache
oh yeah it's dicey and i bought a little
not much
yeah not a lot i wasn't going heavy dog
dog in college me and my roommates
dressed up as you know we didn't have
any costume ideas so
no wait i'm not wearing a lot of another
man's pubic hair around my [ __ ] mouth
dude
like some freak just something young
yeah
that 13 year old mustache in college
nobody had any outfits and we were
throwing the halloween party at our
house in college
so i went don't worry i got this so i
went to [ __ ] ralph's and got uh
depends
the the big diapers i was like wall be
big babies so we all put these diapers
on had nothing else on
we got real wasted and then these hot
chicks walk down here and go
ugh this is disgusting and it hurt our
feelings yeah
you got your feelings hurt yeah hell
yeah yeah that's what you deserve
i'll cheer you the [ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah you thought you're the cool mom if
you want to had me there i would have
cheered you up on that oh yeah he'll
shine your floors
[Laughter]
i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you
i'll clean it up
uh here's frank castillo has a question
right here
shout out to frank
[Music]
is